missile i would ask you
in the coming school year right as we
approach another school year
how many children will die
in school shooting system how many
employees will die in the next 12 months
in the workplace and how many will be
injured
and the fact that your brain right now
is probably trying to calculate
says there's something fundamentally
wrong with the way we deal with these
things because the answer should be zero
the answer should be
you know we're prepared we're trained
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders this episode is a really
impactful one by an entrepreneur who's
working on a product that um will make
us feel safer wherever we are
and
i think we'll make a pretty significant
impact on the world in general meet yoni
scherizen the founder of gabriel
he founded gabriel after witnessing the
hampered response to a terror attack in
tel aviv and a few days later the then
largest mass shooting in the united
states
in turn the only recruited a team of
leading technologists and security
experts to reimagine how we prepare for
and respond to critical incidents
mass shootings has been their initial
focus and gabriel has deployed in soft
target settings such as schools houses
of worship care facilities and office
buildings in april 2022 gabriel was
battle tested when a shooting broke out
at a customer's site and the technology
successfully automated the critical
response to save lives
[Applause]
i appreciate you being here yoni and the
work that you're doing um i've we've
gotten to communicate a little bit in
the past and it's really quite a quite
inspiring and extraordinary that's why i
invited you to come here and share a
little bit about you know your story and
the story of gabrielle and and the
impact that that you're having
um through gabrielle and the impact that
you will have on on so many so many
lives so first of all thank you again
for being here yoni tell me a little bit
about you know where you're coming from
and how do you have even end up
working in this crisis response
domain
yeah it's a great question you know i
spent many years outside of the world of
security even outside the world of
technology uh i decided to take uh what
was supposed to be a small break from
business in order to do work in the
nonprofit space and education
and really want to address social
problems uh you know needs that people
had and kind of giving myself for a few
years before making that transition back
over to business and
that journey ended up being almost 15
years everything from founding
organizations and projects to turning
others around
and then when i did make that transition
over back into business
you know i decided
let's take some of that soul some of
that purpose that we're able to have in
the nonprofit world and bring that over
to a business that delivers good as well
by delivering good will actually be able
to drive success from a business point
of view as well as bring impact into the
world
around that time um you know i witnessed
the impact of a terror attack in tel
aviv and saw how these things unfold
from relatively close range and
really saw how this was a cycle and
there was a you know a process that that
just breaks down
over and over and over again when you
have situations like this and
unfortunately lives are at risk when
when things like this happen and then a
few days later was the pulse nightclub
shooting down in orlando florida which
at the time was the worst mass shooting
in us history and i saw a lot of
similarities in those two situations
thankfully what we experienced in tel
aviv was much less dramatic in terms of
its uh impact you know the number of
people killed and injured
and whereas in florida was you know 49
people and just a a real mess but
um you know when you start scratching
beneath the surface you see a real need
and you know when you look at the sort
of systems that we have in place to
address situations like active shooter
situations terror attacks what you know
a number of different threats
and in fact we found that those same
models apply to many different sort of
scenarios and we said wow you know
there's a blue ocean here a huge
opportunity
in terms of bringing technology to the
fore changing the way these situations
get addressed
and also again delivery social
good tell me a little bit about
current state of affairs you know what
what you've noticed back in the
intersection of these two events you
know
paint me a picture when we have an event
happening let's say
the very unfortunate event where we have
an active a potential active shooter in
a in a school
a reality that we don't want to be in
but but we have
pretty regularly unfortunately what what
happens at that what how do you deal
with that today 2022.
so you know it's somewhat sad to say
that today 2022 we're still dealing with
it in the way that we did many many
years ago and that's why you know we see
the need and that opportunity here
that's right for disruption but there
are a number of manual processes that
take place so messiah if you were to
walk into a building or be in an
environment where all of a sudden you
saw something suspicious
and you thought oh my god i have got to
tell people about this right people
could be at risk
what do you do at that point
do you pick up the phone and call 9-1-1
do you shout to people inside the you
know there's so many different things
that you have to do all at the same time
and you can only choose one because as
much of a superhero as you are you can
solve all those problems at the same
time so and that's where gabriel which
we developed steps in and automates all
of those multiple processes that have to
happen so what needs to take place in
that environment to your question is
number one you need to identify that
threat as early as possible once you've
identified that that threat or that
situation you then need to do all these
things in tandem such as alert people
inside the building so they can get to a
safe place you need to alert on-site
management and security and get them
going in exactly the opposite direction
you want them to go towards the threat
for the the suspicious activity and
isolated and put into it as well as help
that's outside the bill how do you get
them engaged and get them engaged not
only with a just an alert like a
standard trigger or hold-up alarm how do
you give them eyes and ears inside that
situation so that when they do turn up
they turn up much smarter and it's
actually safer for everyone involved
right i think one of the things that you
mentioned to me a few days ago which
were you know really
true i mean you're imagining a situation
in which there is a complex building
right or a complex
area which has different rooms it has
different
different facilities and then you have
you have a threat happening so you have
the first issue which is sort of this
transparency or how do you observability
how do you get everybody around to know
that something is going on even if
they're very very far away right and the
and on the other hand
once the team does get there how do they
even know
where the threat is where you know where
the different people are maybe different
and one of the things that you mentioned
was that gabriel is actually able to
help people
provide input to the enforcement
to try and better assess the situation
so they're not just blind tell me a
little bit about the product the
platform and and how gabrielle works
that's right so you know when we when we
started looking at this you know i came
again from a very different background
and what we did was we recruited some of
the the best and the brightest
and most experienced from the worlds of
security from intelligence from response
from special forces to swat teams etc
and what we found is there are some very
core principles that you have to have in
place and when those things are there it
is literally a game changer and a
lightsaber when they're not there
there's one thing that takes over and
that's chaos
and chaos actually becomes the greatest
threat in a situation like this so those
two things that you would have to have
in that end up in that environment are
number one
visibility and number two communication
in tactical terms we call that
situational awareness and command and
control and what we're trying to do is
democratize those tools out of the
tactical world and get them out into the
hands of people you know in what's
called soft targets and vulnerable
spaces as quickly as possible
but what happens is when you have that
instant visibility and you have that
communication you can number one
understand what's going on where move
people to where they need to get to and
you know avoid a situation where you
might actually send people into the line
of danger in the gabriel what we did was
we we you know we started by saying okay
we've got to detect trouble sooner and
empower people in that environment so we
put help within reach of every hand
everything from a panic button
leveraging all the smartphones right
putting or any smart devices layering
software onto those devices in the
environment so that you transform them
into life-saving devices in real time
not just you know something again to
call 911 for call family member so
number one
putting help within reach of eddie hand
number two we want to also hook into any
and all the existing infrastructure in
the system and pull that into our
platform cameras pa systems etc so that
you can instantly create a clear picture
of what's going on layer that onto the
floor plan again think about does does
your local police department for first
responder have access to your up-to-date
floor plan the answer unfortunately in
most cases is no so through gabriel
we're automatically feeding them that
information with visibility layered onto
it and the ability to communicate inside
the scene even before they've arrived so
by doing that we're automating those
processes streamlining it all but then
mikhail you touched on a really
important point and what we learned was
that everyone in the security world or
when something bad happens we all become
very myopic we all worry about what's
happening with me and my goal my
business my space but what's happening
next door
you know we have a responsibility if you
go back to that scenario where you might
have seen something suspicious are you
going to call out to the people inside
the building i sure hope so but what
about the folks next door if this
perpetrator doesn't get in
for it does damage and then goes next
door we need to make sure those people
know as well so we leverage a network
effect and create a community approach
to security
fantastic
and there was an event that actually
happened that
that this was uh this played a pretty
interesting role in right tell me tell
me a little bit about this sort of case
study that you've participated in
yourself
that's right uh you know when we when we
built gabriel we we hoped that we would
never be
faced with a real live scenario right i
used to always say we we hope to never
face the situation but we hope to do
drill after drill and educate a new
generation and empower a whole
generation with the tools they need for
the unthinkable and unfortunately um in
april the unthinkable happened on our
doorstep um
the campus that
is using our platform
uh
as as most of these situations it was
somewhat of an insider threat meaning
someone who was known to the environment
and
um all of a sudden in the middle of a
very complex campus with a lot of very
vulnerable people
gunshots ring out
and
one another and it keeps going and
thankfully gabriel was there to
immediately alert and isolate that
situation and put it to an end uh
unfortunately one person did lose their
life uh in that horrible scenario but
we're proud to be able to say that we
were we helped isolate again that the
instant visibility to know what was
happening
where inside that campus to get everyone
to safety keep them away from trouble
and including people who weren't
familiar there were a number of guests
uh even you know outside meetings that
were taking place on the campus that if
they if they hadn't known they very
easily could have walked right into the
line of fire and here in this situation
we were able to very quickly apprehend
the individual
isolate the threat keep everyone away um
and you know thankfully we're now
expanding that that rollout not only
um further into that campus and other
sites but also neighbors nearby who now
see the valley
right and and obviously just to clarify
this is not you it's the gabriel is sort
of the the software that's behind
the aid to the enforcement that shows up
right and uh and so this is an aid for
that but tell me you know you mentioned
um you know how you personally were
involved with that what is that like for
you
you know as sort of the leader here
right the visionary the ex the person
who's running this trip all of a sudden
for the first time you are seeing your
platform in action
so so now from the head of sort of the
the entrepreneur or the person who's out
there to really make an impact tell me
how did you experience
that situation in real time
yeah one of the key tools that we built
in in value that we provide for our
customers is that they really have a
security operations center or a command
room in the palm of their pocket right a
lot of these people
would never have access to a command
room and those sorts of tools and we
every you know they can have a
distributed security team that really
jump in and help manage the situation um
you know as a founder and someone who
cares deeply about this i insist that
i'm part of every environment on the
platform so i always know what's going
on and i always know you know if things
aren't up to scratch or who know you
know if they're drilling etc um that i
get alerted and i was home in israel
wrestling my daughter to sleep um
at the the end of my patients to be
honest
and i said you know honey for the last
time get off the sofa and let's go to
bed
and my phone goes off right and it's a
siren followed by lockdown emergency
every one of our alerts has an action
that comes with it and she turns to me
and she goes dad is it another false
alarm
or just a drill
and i pull out my phone
and i look at it it tells me exactly
which device we actually have our own
hardware sensors as well that we put
into the environment and that it tells
me which device which campus where
inside the campus it was triggered and
it gives me instant video from that to
video and audio from that sensor then i
open it up and i see people scrambling
could still be a false alarm
i hit the 10 second rewind because we're
always recording in advance to give that
contextual information
and i see and i hear gunshots and it's a
very different situation
and at that point i said to the family
you know i need to excuse myself
and moved into a room and really became
part of the first response team from
halfway around the world um so
we originally built this so that a
remote or distributed security and
management team could manage it from the
other side of a building or the other
side of the city but what we actually
found was that even being halfway around
the world we were able to help remotely
um and just as the responders again from
from very nearby can help and get access
to that information inside the scene and
begin their response even before they
physically turn up um you know i was
really you know part of that and on the
inside um again on the one hand
upsetting you know we never want to see
these things but missile i would ask you
in the coming school year right as we
approach another school year
how many children will die
in school shootings this how many
employees
will die in the next 12 months in the
workplace and how many will be injured
and the fact that your brain right now
is probably trying to calculate
says there's something fundamentally
wrong with the way we deal with these
things because the answer should be zero
the answer should be
you know we're prepared we're trained
right
a hundred years ago we were panicking in
fires and dying from smoke inhalation
and transportation and trampolines but
we've been able today to train to put in
the right systems and educate a
generation because i don't believe a
child will die from a fire at a school
the next year it hasn't happened in a
long time and i sure hope it won't
happen this year right that would be
very surprising but the fact that we put
up with people dying in the workplace
and in schools means there's something
fundamentally wrong
yep we can definitely both both agree on
that
tell me a little bit about
from you know you started out on um
talking about you know non-profits
business finding alignment you know this
is classic
impact investing right i mean that you
know this is the the whole theory of if
we can find a business plan that that
makes
you know linear correlation of impact
and positive roi for society that's that
that's that how do you so how do we
scale this how how do you get this thing
to be in in every school and every
office what what is sort of the go-to
market strategy that you're employing
here to get this to scale as much as
possible
yeah the go to market strategy here and
i think that we learned that because
this is such a sensitive subject and
people
uh don't want to make the wrong choice
number one
and number two because regulation has
not yet required a solution like this in
every building right i believe it it's
on its way and it will take time but
it's on its way the way that every
space that has lots of people has a fire
alarm one day will require the blue
cousin to the fire alarm and that will
be a hundred times smarter than the
systems we employ for smoke and fire
so we're we're ahead of the curve on
that and that's what we're pushing but
what we learned is that because it's
such a sensitive subject going in with
partners who already have that
relationship and the trust of the
customer is often very helpful so you've
got your you know like the classic
startup you have you have the
the early adopters the very early
adopters who are you know very into
technology they love new things and
they're they're super concerned about
safety and security that is a small
fraction of the market the majority of
the market like many markets and
products right those need to have
um but the product that they're that
they're familiar with often coming from
a brand that they're familiar with so
those those key partners are are
important but go into your question
about impact
then it brings another layer of
complexity you don't want to just sell
through any channel partner any reseller
it means you need to find those that
really align with your values your core
mission and you know they're going to
carry the ethos of your product out into
the marketplace as well so that's in it
and by the way i would say it's true for
staff it's true for advisory board
members it's true for investors it's
true for charitable partners turning
down the ones who are not the right
ethos have been some of the most
important lessons that we've learned in
decisions we've taken along the way
how is gabriel's story
a lot what how is gabriel's story
related to yoni's story to the story
that you're creating for yourself in
your own life in your own journey
how what role does gabriel play in that
you know i think we all want to be
impactful
right we all want to move the needle
whether that's when you wake up in the
morning you go to work you want to know
that you're you're achieving something
you come home you want to know that
you're achieving something you're moving
something you're you're making a
difference to other people
into the world around you
and
you know when i was making this
transition back over to the business
world i i heard uh a great lecture about
what motivates employees it's mastery
autonomy and purpose
we want to be good at what we do we want
to have the space to achieve it and we
want to know that we're doing something
meaningful
and when i looked at the various
opportunities i had whether it was in
the investing world or real estate or a
number of different things
i didn't necessarily see that fit and
when someone's doing a job that doesn't
align with them at a personal level
then they dry up right they get they
they get bored they get slow that
eventually it might slowly or quickly
eat away at them and it's just not gonna
work and i use this mantra when i hire
right you've got to get the right person
for the right role in the right company
at the right time and trying to push
someone you love
into a company or a role that's not
really right for them is not going to
work out well for everyone so in my
personal
journey in my personal story
it was about keeping that impact the
ability to add something significant to
the world yet also do great business so
i spent 15 years smashing my head
against the wall
you know reading
management books and you know an mba and
all that stuff and trying to bring that
into the non-profit space and now i've
turned it the other way around and we're
running a business but we're gonna run a
business that treats people well that
delivers value and makes the world a
better place
yoni very inspiring thank you so much
for coming and sharing your journey uh
20 minutes doesn't do it justice but um
inspiring nonetheless so thank you very
very much best of luck with gabriel i
hope to see this in every school and
every facility um
i literally you know being the
dealing with
probably the most important
few moments that
we may spontaneously encounter which is
a very unfortunate reality that we live
in but but it's one that we can't ignore
and so you're not ignoring it you're
tackling it
um and uh thank you for dedicating so
much of your time to this and best of
luck with gabrielle and i look forward
to keeping in touch thank you michael
all the best
thank you
[Music]